In Saudi Arabia, criticism grows as the government begins investigation...
...into the Hajj stampede that killed more than 700 and injured over 800 people.
In the United States, Pope Francis addresses the United Nations General Assembly...
...on climate change, world conflict and the refugee crisis.
Air pollution in Indonesia threatens the Eid celebration and everyday life...
...as the Pollutant Standards Index calls air quality "very unhealthy".
In Greece, Prime Minister Alexis Tsipras promises to lead the country...
...out of debt by 2019, with reform and debt relief his priorities.
And finally from Switzerland, the police are to open a criminal investigation...
...into Sepp Blatter's role in the FIFA bribery scandal.